-Guys, the NASCAR Cup
Series Championship
airs this Sunday,
right here on NBC,
on your television!
[ Cheering and applause ]
We love NASCAR.
Now, at the end of the series,
they give out an award
for Most Popular Driver,
but they also give out
some other awards as well.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Tonight Show ♪
♪ Superlatives ♪
♪♪
-Now, our first driver is...
He was voted...
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I go fast around the corners."
[ Laughter ]
Up next, we have...
[ Awws and applause ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Wow!"
-"Is this a dream?"
-"Oh, my gosh!
Where's my milk?"
-"Santa!"
[ Laughter ]
Next up, we have...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-♪ Zaltrex ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Scat singing funk ]
♪♪
Up next, we have...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh,
because he's a little teapot.
-Yeah.
They call him Little Teapot.
-He's both short and stout.
-[ Southern accent ]
Here comes Little Teapot
around the corner.
-[ Matching accent ] Coming
right here, short and stout.
[ Imitates vuvuzela blast ]
Brrr!
-Up next, we have...
-Ooh!
-He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You only have rhombuses?
Oh, I'll come back."
[ Laughter ]
Next up is...
-Ooh!
-He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm going to fight for you."
Up next, we have...
[ Audience awws ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"You are full of beans."
-"Oh, you."
[ Laughter ]
Do you like it? "Oh, you."
-"Yeah."
-Next up, we have...
-Ooh.
-He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, we have...
-Oh.
-He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Not today, not ever!"
[ Cheering and applause ]
And, finally, we have...
He was voted...
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are your "Superlatives."